so the next topic in our program we
would like to highlight
has nothing to do with food but with
feelings
to be more precisely with empathy and i
would like to talk about this
with yasi hassan he is a social
psychologist for social change at the
hebrew university in jerusalem director
of research at arkor
hello shalom nice meeting you
hello nice to meet you together with his
colleague anat
amir who is a scientist and an artist
he has conducted a most interesting life
experiment
to try to increase empathy between
different groups and my first question
is can you
talk a little bit about empathy how do
you define
embassy actually
yeah it's a good question so empathy
involves sharing and understanding
the emotions and situation of others so
when a friend of mine
shares a sad story i would feel a bit of
his sadness
and if this friend is angry about
something i would feel part of this
anger as well so the ability to share
and understand
others is fundamental and important for
human interactions because
it leads us to care for each other
and how did your interest in this field
and this topic emerge what is
fascinating for you about this
yes so actually what is most fascinating
is the fact that although
empathy is important we find that people
tend to feel more empathy toward people
from their own group and less empathy
towards people
from other groups and this this
phenomenon called intergroup empathy
bias
and it becomes a barrier in promoting
intergroup
relation this is true almost in any
context
between ethnic groups religious group
national groups and political groups
and you can find this barrier in almost
any country
you can think about conservatives and
liberals in
in germany jews and arabs in israel or
christian and muslim in the united
states
and yes can you explain what is the
topic of
and the focus of your research and what
impact can it have on societies
yes so my research tried to understand
the mechanism actually what drives
people to feel empathy or to avoid
empathy in interview context and by
understanding this mechanism
i try to develop psychological
interventions to
overcome those barriers and to promote
empathy
between groups and the reason i'm doing
it is because i believe that
by finding way to increase empathy
between groups we can create a better
society so by increasing empathy would
be able to reduce negative attitudes
discrimination and violence between
groups and also try to
increase pro-social behavior and
solidarity between
green groups that's interesting
josie can we talk about the events you
are
offering at the berlin science summit um
the title of your session is believing
empathy
is unlimited um can you give us a
preview
into what happened during the experiment
that made you conclude this
yeah of course so in the last few years
anatomy and i have been developing
an innovative concept that combines live
performance art
and social psychology experiment that
aim to alter
to change people's basic assumptions
about the limitation of empathy
so in this collaboration between art and
psychology
it's been done through a framework of
theater performance that attract
audience 500
of hundreds that also act as
participants in empathy experiment and
they have the
the opportunity to interact with people
from their own group
and other groups and what we find is
that
when people tend to believe that empathy
is limited okay that they cannot
feel empathy toward many peoples the
truth
they keep their empathy to their own
group and they avoid
feeling empathy to toward other groups
but in our experiments and actually
performance
we we challenge jesus this belief and we
make them believe that empathy is
unlimited and what we find it when we
change this belief
people become more empathetic toward
others and even engage in more
pro-social behavior toward
others and this concept has been
tested and conducted in the united
states in israel
and we hopefully try to to do the same
in germany in half a year
and trying to increase empathy between
the general community and
and muslim community well thank you very
much
yossi hassan for this interview we're
looking forward to your session
it's a great way to learn more about
your own empathy
thank you so much